hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game from the final round of
the rapid section of the super United
Blitz tournament in Croatia in Zagreb
it's a Jordan Palm Forest versus alireza
firuja and after this game you will
never again have the fear facing the
Berlin defense because this is just a a
very refreshing and a very new way of
dealing with it it's not um it's not
completely new uh there have been
attempts at the trying this on the on
the absolute top level but they didn't
really go all that well yeah so without
further Ado let's check it out and see
what we mean by this uh the leaders
basically of the tournament
um uh Clash for for first place who will
Who will take the Rapids so Jordan opens
with E4 we have E5 like we said is going
to be a nice Berlin Knight to C6 Bishop
to B5 The Rue Lopez is on the board and
Knight to F6 the Berlin defense is also
on the board uh castles and Knight
captures on e4 accepting the Rio Gambit
with Rook to E1 and the Knights the D6
now this is all very very standard stuff
we've seen this many many times Knight
captures on E5 Bishop to E7 and now we
have to move the bishop back so Bishop
to F1 Knight captures an E5 Rook
captures and now uh alireza castles with
Pawn to D4 Bishop to F6 chasing away The
Rook Rook to E1 and now a rook to E8 and
here uh there are a couple of moves that
are very popular here for example C3
just strengthening the pawn here
capturing The Rook here is a very
popular developing the bishop is very
popular but the move you're in place has
only been played a handful of times he
plays Knight to the C3 which makes sense
you develop a knight but what happens if
just Rook captures an E1 Queen captures
and Bishop captures on D4 it seems like
it's a free Pawn uh so what ex exactly
do you do game from this well uh let's
uh let's uh check out and see uh as
Extreme Measures are required to crush
the Berlin defense so here we have
Bishop capture uh sorry Rook captures
any one first queen captures and Bishop
captures on D4 well it is a wins upon
and uh what does Jordan have to show for
it well at the Knight on D6 is uh very
oddly placed now with with this exact uh
position of all the pieces and pawns uh
the problem is you have to move it you
have to move this pawn and then only
then will you be able to continue your
development so here uh in the game that
I mentioned Corona versus Wesley so I
was played also in the grand Chester but
in the Paris rapid tournament in their
Fabi played Bishop to F4 which is the
absolute top move recommended by the
engine but uh um Jordan goes for
something else he plays Bishop to D3 and
now it is as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
alireza deals with this he plays Bishop
captures in C3 uh you don't have to play
this but
um uh it uh the bishop is also very very
a very oddly place for example yeah you
might uh let's say you try to develop
the night night the fortnite we want to
play D6 to develop the bishop already
Queen to E4 and you can resign there's
the thread of Queen captures on H7 and
just Queen captures on D4 so not very
good for the bishop to remain there so
while it is are just the trade this
bishop captures in C3 Queen characters
and now Knights the E8 so now we have B3
the bishop is coming to B2 of course we
wanna have this diagonal all to
ourselves the Ponte D6 and Bishop to B2
so what did Jordan get for his Pawn well
he has the bishop bear which is already
justified in itself and he has the uh
Bishop pair nicely aiming at the
blacking and it's also very very easy to
get the Rook into the attack for example
rookie one rookie 3 Rook to G3 or H3 uh
all of your pieces are attacking the
black king and alireza still has the uh
develop well start developing for the
price of that one Pawn so uh for
classical maybe not so great but for
rapid and Blitz should work just fine
Bishop to E6 and now we have Queen the
B4
uh attacking the the B7 Pawn here and
this is where uh uh Jordan is seemingly
out prepared alireza it would seem you
have to defend the pawn with Rook to B8
but even then you are you know just
playing a weird position that has never
been reached before but here yeah it is
a place Bishop to D5 makes sense you
defend the pawn and you have your own
Bishop attacking the white king but now
just Queen to F4 and again there are
there are some problems here uh the
bishop on D5 is undefended and you could
run into uh uh you could run into a lot
of trouble here so just Knight to F6
defending the bishop and defending the
H7 pawn and it now comes Rook to E1 this
is the absolute best move and the only
way to push for the win here if you try
some tricky Bishop captures on H7 moves
that uh you know it seems like it's fine
Knight captures let's say you go uh
Queen before you threaten Checkmate and
threatened to win back your piece uh
just Queen G5 uh defense Checkmate
defense the bishop here so no no problem
so Rook to E1 the move Jordan plays is
indeed the way to go we have Bishop back
to E6 alirez again has to waste the move
because the bishop and D5 is undefended
in a very weirdly placed it is defended
by the Knight but uh it it's not you
know the best yeah so here Rook the E3
we are getting that free rook Lift King
to f8 uh and now Pawn to C4 you could
also play Rook to F3 yeah Jordan first
wants to make his Pawn structure here uh
nicely and nicely set up we have Knight
the H5 now attacking the queen and queen
to F3 just attacking the Knight Knight
back to F6 and here Queen captures on B7
so you win your Pawn back and you have
the bishop pair and a really really
awesome position so here Knights the G4
attacking The Rook just rooked the G3
now if you move the Knight of course
there's gonna be a problem uh Rook the
B8 chases the queen back and now Queen
to E4 now just threatening to win
material so here Queen to G5 you could
also bring the Knight back to F6 but it
really doesn't help Queen to G5 while it
is a now comes Queen captures on H7 uh
King to E7 and now comes Queen captures
on G7 and this is uh one move that
allows alireza to get back into the game
uh it's not all that clear why but it
will become clear uh once so we continue
the game but just to show you an example
if you go for Bishop captures on G7
instead then the queen covers the H2
Pawn that's you know it seems weird from
this position but look at this queen to
D2 attacks the F2 pawn and the bishop
you're gonna play Rook to F3 uh to keep
everything defended Queen to E1 check
you have to play Bishop back to F1 and
not Knight captures on H2 and that's the
problem only uh it's not a problem as
the queen covers the H2 square if the
queen wasn't covering the H2 Square
you'd have to capture it in Queen
captures on F1 and so on which is
exactly what happened in the game as
Jordan played Queen captures on G7 so
now Queen to D2
threatens a check here also putting
pressure on the bishop also putting
pressure on the bishop also putting
pressure on the F2 Pawn so the pieces
are protected but the F2 Pawn is not so
Rook to F3 Queen to E1 check Bishop to
F1 and now Knight captures on H2 this is
what holiday is defines as now the queen
is no longer guarding this this H2 Pawn
King captures on H2 and now Queen
captures an F1 we have C5 this is the
only way to continue pushing for the win
and here all it is a completely blunders
the game uh you have to uh you know
start bringing your king to safety but
alireza played Queen to D1 and now you
have one move that just ends the game so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this move while I give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
if the king did not have the D7 Square
you can just resign and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course Pawn to C6 this is what alireza
missed and as soon as he saw this he
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so really a
beautiful beautiful win against the
Berlin defense with that pawn sacrifice
that kinda you know yeah you just
sacrifice a pawn and you have a Bishop's
pair and then easy way to get your Rook
into the attack I mean uh who would not
go for this is just a beautiful
beautiful way to approach uh fighting
the Berlin and I think it could become
very very popular if you you know play
online you know you face the main line
and you know it could be could be
popular so here you resign because
there's really nothing to do uh if
Bishop to F6 check you're gonna have to
move the king back and then Queen to G8
will be Checkmate so basically the only
way to stop this is to play Rook f8 um
uh that way you will not have to worry
about Queen the Jeep check but still the
shop to F6 with check King T8 now Bishop
to H4 and there's no defense against
this Checkmate or this Checkmate it's
unplayable you could play Queen D5
hoping let's say for Queen F6 and then
Queen E5 check the trade of the Queens
but after rookie 3 you take away this
queen uh Square from the black queen and
now there's nothing Queen captures and
C6 can be played but now you run into
Rook characters and E6 with check and
now if you capture this is Checkmate and
if you don't capture you're just down
material and you're gonna get checkmate
fairly soon uh so yeah after a C6
resigns and a spectacular victory for
Jordan Palm Forest who even after losing
that game to Magnus Carlsen
gets the first place these are the
standings after nine rounds of the of
the rapid section you're in Palm Forest
with 12 points in first place uh with 11
points uh we have shared between Magnus
Carlsen withly so in all it is a firozan
with 10 Maxima gravity with nine uh with
eight on near Dominguez with seven even
charged with 6 and a vessel into palav
with Five Points so really an awesome
awesome start to the tournament and now
we have two more days of Blitz and then
we are going to see who will take the uh
the the Croatia Grand Chester rapid and
Blitz tournament uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh very
very nicely done by Jordan I'm pretty
sure the Knight of C3 line could pick up
very easily at least in shorter time
formats uh I would like to thank Gordon
Mercer tangotsolovarai Travis Michael
Colbert and Kevin Klein for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day